Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine and today we have got the brand-new red
iPhone 8 plus this also comes in the regular sized iPhone 8 version and they also announced a new red leather folio case.
So not only are so many of you guys huge fans of the color red
But the red color is not just a color, over the past 11 years
Apple has donated over a hundred and sixty million dollars to the product red charity. Red is a charity that provides
Testing and counseling and treatments to tens of millions of people living around the world with AIDS and HIV, so yes
It is a red iPhone, but it is for a good cause and today,
We are going to unbox that and I am so excited because when I saw these photos
I was freaking out the news had already broke on the East Coast
And I was just waking up over here on the west coast and I was like yes!
They have a black front the previous red iPhone that they released it was a beautiful red back
But the front of it was white. So it seems like Apple has listened to our feedback and guess what it's here so, sit back,
Relax, and enjoy this wonderful unboxing. I know you guys have never seen me unbox and iPhone before so..
Let's unbox, and yes, I do realize that there is a pull tab right here, but what fun is that?
So here we have.
Oh! Here it is. No! Oh my goodness
That was surprising. I wasn't ready to look so we've got our phone. We've got a dongle. We've got our earbuds
We've got a power brick and some wonderful literature
instructions just in case
You don't know how to use it
Product read pamphlet in partnership with red apple will contribute a portion of your iPhone purchase to the Global Fund to support
hiv/aids programs and help deliver an aids-free generation
Learn more or donate at RED.org
We've also got our lightning cable, so I've yet to look at the back of the phone. I'm gonna show it to you guys first
Wow
This is a very
Very deep red it looks so good.
The best part about the iPhone 8 is the all glass back you guys recall I did have the iPhone 8 in the
Rose gold and it is probably to date my absolute favorite color of phone
Yet that Apple has ever released with the all glass back and the aluminum band around it, by far
This is my favorite design of iphone to date
It is a really
Really really really nice look like I am actually quite a shook. I was so excited about it
I said to my sister, and she's like so
is there are an iPhone X version of this cuz I'm pretty sure she was about to run to the store and upgrade her X
I'm sure a lot of you guys are probably questioning
Why did Apple not release an iPhone 10 version of this red phone not actually sure
But either way I feel like there is still a huge market for the iPhone 8 because this phone is basically an iPhone X
Without facial recognition it really is a preference essentially the iPhone 8 is almost the same exact phone as the iPhone X
But with a touch ID it also doesn't do facial recognition
There are a few other features that it doesn't have over the iPhone X, but I feel like at this point
it is a preference and I love that this is still a choice for people and especially if you are in the market for a
New phone, and you want red? This is really beautiful the all-black front a completely flushed edge to edge
It's honestly
Really great-looking. It's so hard because I'm looking at this with my eyes
And I'm hoping that I can portray how incredible this looks to you guys hold on, I'm smudging it up already
I need to give you guys a good look. I think now's a pretty good time for a slow-mo montage
It's it's
Dusty guys this is behind the scenes of things you don't see. oh no goodness. You look beautiful keep up the good work
Thank you so much for watching I hope you guys enjoyed this video
I would love to hear your feedback of what you guys think of this phone
I definitely recommend if you have an Apple Store by you
Go in and look at it in person because it is a really beautiful deep red. I mean it's I just I
feel like it's an art piece.
Think this is something that I want hanging on my wall it might be a little bit difficult taking phone calls um
Yeah, sorry. I can't hear you because I've decided that I was going to hang up my phone on the wall as art
Let me know if you have any more suggestions for some videos that you'd like to see here in the future and don't forget to
Subscribe and also make sure you hit that little bell so that you'll be notified when I post new videos
And with that I will see you guys in my next video. Bye